Okay let's begin with May the 23rd 1926 and tonight we're going to have an absolutely wonderful
wonderful teaching on the unity of the divine will and this first message on May the 23rd
introduces us to that by telling us the power of even one act in the divine will. This is something
absolutely incredible and that we need to tell people who are beginning the journey in the divine
will we need to tell them rather quickly so that they will appreciate what journey they're actually
becoming to participate in. So Louisa said I was accompanying my sweet Jesus in his sorrowful agony
in the garden especially when all the weight of our sins unloaded itself upon his most holy humanity
to the point of making him shed living blood. Oh how I would have wanted to relieve him from
the pain so excruciating so while I sympathized with his whole being he told me now we begin my
daughter he said my will because his will is divine has the power to give death and to give life.
Now if you're studying the book of Revelation with me you have seen in chapters 17, 18, 19 and 20
that the divine will can give death because that is the final judgment that some souls will be thrown
into the lake of burning sulfur. It can give life eternal life and he's going to go on and emphasize
the life here by telling us that if you die having made just one act in the divine will it's going
to have eternal consequences so I want to give you a whole lot of scriptures because there's a lot
of scriptural background for everything we're doing tonight. One is John 14 6 I am the way the
truth and the life and I want to give you Sam 59 16, Sam 62 11, Sam 63 2 and Sam 66 7 and it's
really good to look up the scriptures because you will see that everything that the Lord teaches
us in the divine will he has taught step by step throughout the centuries so that when in the end
he would actually make the revelation we would be ready for it just as our generation is actually
ready for this while what is being offered to us is astonishing we accept it very easily generations
before us couldn't have accepted it very easily so he says my will has the power to give death and
to give life and since my humanity now this is Jesus in the flesh okay my humanity knew
no other life but the life of the divine will now you could write a whole book on that that means
of while he was living in the flesh everything totally absolutely was divine will the body was
completely under the divine will he gave the the body no life of its own everything was divine
will my humanity knew no other life but the life of the divine will so as the sins crowded over me
now we're talking about in this section we're talking about what I call the passion of Jesus
during his hidden life so it didn't just happen in Gethsemane it was happening for all of his life
so pacific to Gethsemane he said as the sins crowded over me my will made me feel a distinct
death for each sin put very simply the Lord has allowed himself to experience our hell that was
due to us for any mortal sin that we've committed my will made me feel a distinct death for each sin
I've often said down the years I've said it to priests that I absolutely cannot grasp that they
don't shiver when they say I absolve you from your sins because at that moment Jesus is speaking
the priest can't absolve us he can only give us what the Lord has actually prepared
but the sheer enormity of simply saying I absolve you and the sheer enormity of a priest saying
this is my body and this is my blood I do not know how priests are not completely overcome
by the enormity of the privilege and the responsibility that they have
so Jesus said he experienced a distinct death for each sin that means that the agony is beyond
anything we could imagine my humanity moaned under the pain of the real death now the real
death for sin is the second death those of you who are in the book of revelation know what I'm
talking about the second death as hell I experienced a real death which my supreme will gave me but
over that very death which the divine will gave me it made the new life of grace rise again for
souls so Jesus experienced within himself my death and resurrection from sin so if you and I are
living without sin which you have to be if you're living in the divine will if we are living without
sin he has paid for every single moment of that and he has enabled me to rise from the death of
sin to the life of grace this is wonderful evangelization stuff so as evil and bad as a creature might be
if the soul has the good fortune of letting one act of my will enter into herself this is extremely
important put a VIP beside it even at the point of death since my will is life the divine will
so is the seed of divine life in the soul that the soul may be saved because the power of my will
will be careful so that this act of life which is its own which has entered into the soul will
not perish now we've been told for many volumes before now that Jesus has repeated over and over
and over again that what the divine will create it the divine will preserves so if the divine will
has allowed a soul to make one genuine act in the divine will he will preserve that to eternal life
the enormity of that I think couldn't be measured it's just astonishing
it will be careful so that this act of life of its own which has entered into the soul may not
perish and turn into death in fact my will has the power to give death as I have mentioned already
from the book of Revelation chapters 1920 but my will itself now it can give death to something
that is absolutely unworthy of it okay but my will itself and all of its acts are untouchable
because they are divine and they are not subject to any death now I want you to underline that bit
the divine will acts genuine divine will act are not subject to any death that means that
when the body has to lay down itself in the earth the divine will acts in that soul go on
into God's presence with the soul they're not subject to any death now if only one act of my
will contains the seed of life what will not be the good fortune of one who embraces within her
own soul not one act only but continuous acts in the divine will in other words if this is the
reality for just one act in the divine will what was it going to be like for those of us who are
trying to live that way 24 7 365 this creature receives not just the seed of life but the fullness
of life and places her sanctity in safety you really really really need to sit down with that
and let it sink in it's just incredible so the continuous acts in the divine will
puts your sanctity in safety now in many of the volumes leading up to this the Lord has been
talking about putting the divine will in safety and putting the graces of redemption in safety
and all the rest of it and now he's telling us how to put your own sanctity in safety as well
by doing these continuous acts in the divine will one of the questions that people starting out
in volume one ask is you know how many acts do you have to actually do you know I mean is there
a limit and the point is there isn't because you're entering a divine will so in the next
paragraph the time of redemption can be called Mary's time and then in the following paragraph
then the time of the divine will is Louise's time we've had this before and he's telling us again
afterwards Louise said my poor mind was wandering in the holy divine will doing my usual acts in it
it seemed to me that everything was mine because Jesus keeps on repeating the fact that when you become
one with the divine will what is his is yours and what yours is his seems to me everything was mine
and I went around through all creation things to impress everywhere with my I love you my adoration
my glory to my creator I acquired new knowledge of what God had done for the creature now what she's
saying here is as you do your rounds that is if you really do them at the depth that they should be
done you will grow in knowledge and understanding and she said I acquired new knowledge of what God
had done for the creature and of how he has shown his great love for us okay now the supreme will
seemed to delight in making known the new surprises of its love so that I might follow its acts
in order for it to give me the right to possess what has come out of its creative will now you have
to take this slowly here she is putting her I love you and glory to my creator on absolutely
everything so that she can give adoration and praise and all the rest of it and she's saying
that the response of the divine will was to take delight in showing new surprises of his love
so that louisa could follow its acts and in following its acts that she would acquire
the right to possess what had come out of the divine will so notice none of this is automatic
this is entirely the relationship between you and the divine will and how you respond to the divine
will and how he responds to you so there's going to be saints in the divine will great and small
my littleness wandered amid its immense goods we'll talk about that in the next section in the
meantime my sweet Jesus came out from within my interior that means the kingdom of God is within
1 Corinthians 3 16 and he told me my daughter when my queen mother came out to the light of day when
she was born everyone was turned towards her and as though having one single gaze all pupils
looked to the one who was going to dry their tears by bringing then the life of the longed for a
redeemer so her position in history is completely unique and unrepeatable she was going to dry
the tears of the human race and therefore what he's saying here is that they the combined longing
of the human race for a savior he's saying that was the gaze of the human race upon her and of course
Paul tells us in Romans 8 19 that the whole of creation was longing for redemption so Jesus is
saying that was all centered on her and all creation was centered on her feeling honored to obey her
wishes the divinity itself was all for her and all intent on her in order to prepare her and to
form her now why would this be it's because the entire solution to the human race was coming through
her the solution to the human race was a savior and it had to be a divine person becoming man
so she had to be prepared and so all of the seas of graces and everything were for the sake of
making a correct tabernacle on the earth for him that's what he's saying here the divinity
itself was all for her and all intent on her in order to prepare her and to form in her with
surprising graces the space into which the eternal word would descend to take human flesh now john says
in john 114 that the word was made flesh and tabernacled among us so mary is that tabernacle
or the ark of the covenant whichever way you want to look at it so there's god creating a space for
him in a human being now i want to solve a problem here that is in these texts all the time it's the
wrong use of the word virtue let's look at it now if the virtue we're not present within us
now in english that doesn't make sense that while we operate deal with or speak to one creature we
wouldn't elect all the others now if you look up the word virtue in a good dictionary it comes
through the word vertus in latin which means manliness or courage another use of the word in the english
language is that it is the practice of moral excellence or righteousness and the only way
we can use this word in one of the ways that it's used in this book is we say something is by virtue
of or by reason of okay therefore the word virtue can't be applied to god at all it's completely
wrong and this is why i have been continuously replacing the word virtue with power let's see
now i haven't seen the original text so i don't know the actual word she used it's just the
translator used the word virtue and created problems for us so let's try the word power if the power
were not present within us that while we operate and deal with or speak to one creature we do not
neglect the others all would have said to us leave all of us aside think only of the virgin now it
makes sense because god has the power because he's omnipotent he can do anything he likes and he can
be omnipresent he can be present to everybody so now if i change that word virtue to power the
whole thing makes sense theologically and it makes sense in english language as well unfortunately
the word virtue is used in different ways just to confuse you in this text i don't mean this
particular text put in these volumes so god is saying he's omnipotent he can do anything
and that was said to our blessed mother as well at the time of the enunciation nothing is impossible
with god in the old testament the way the lord used to say it to the people who are struggling
like joshua for example when he was conquering the promised land is the arm of the lord too short
that means does god's power have limits and so god is omnipresent and he can do everything so
while he is dealing with one person he's dealing with everybody else as well
okay and if you look at some of the meditations of the saints and the people who are called blessed
by the church meditating on the birth of jesus and bethlehem one of the ones i love and i think
it comes from don marmian he said that the child who suckled his mother's breast was ruling the world
the child who needed to be wrapped in swaddling clothes
was receiving souls after death and judging them and so you know the saints had the ability to
touch the eternal reality that was going on and not just get stuck on the the material and the
physical so he's omnipotent he can do anything you notice in the resurrection of jesus that jesus
could be in many places at the same time so what jesus is saying here is that if the human race
were given a choice they would have said put all your attention upon this version because the
solution is there now i want to compare that with john 17 where jesus is actually praying
just before his death for his church and he said to the father i pray for them not for the world
now you'd say to yourself but he came to save the world why is he not praying for the world
he's not praying for the world because all attention has to be given to his apostles
because if the apostles get it right the world will be okay they will be looked after
if the virgin who must bring forth the messiah if she's okay then the rest of the world will
eventually be okay so this is giving all the attention now what we're doing is preparing for
the lord saying to louisa this is why i have to give you all the attention because everybody coming
after you is depending on you making it through but that's actually where he's going with this
so the text then says leave all of us aside and think of this virgin only
centralize everything in her that she may let the one come in whom our hope that is the redeemer
our life and all our good are placed all our hopes for the future all our prayers all our size
are for a redeemer and it's all going to come from her so centralize everything in her and
make sure that she has it now we've already dealt with texts and which jesus explained the centralizing
of all redemption in the virgin and centralizing all to do with the divine will in louisa therefore
jesus concludes the time in which the sovereign queen came to the light of day can be called the
time of mary the time of my mother he said and then he goes on immediately and said this my daughter
can be called your time so we go on to louisa's time because he he's using the same technique
all the time to explain something to louisa he explains his mother's calling to explain louisa's
office he explains his mother's office to explain the grace going into louisa he explains his mother
so that louisa has something to compare with so he says right now that's in the 20th century
all our turn towards you i hear the voice of all as if they were one praying to me pressing me
that my will may acquire its absolute rights over you so that acquiring its total dominion
it may pour into you all the fullness of the goods that the divine will had established to give
if the creature had not withdrawn from my will so jesus is saying just as god the father heard the
prayer of all the saints of the old testament now jesus is saying that god the father has heard
the prayer of all the saints of the new testament and all of us in the divine will praying for the
kingdom of the divine will to come to pass so he's heard all of our prayers he has heard all the prayers
of the future everything is present to him that's going to be the message in the next message on
may the 27th but everything is centralized in him he can hear everything but we call past present
and future it's all present to him and he said i listened to that prayer now what he's saying is
prayers that have not yet been prayed because they're still in the future he has heard them
our aching prayer that the divine will would come on the earth and rule on the earth that's all
being heard he said and the result of it is that he raised up luisa so that he could open the door
it's a fascinating thought so he said the whole of heaven our celestial mother the angels and the
saints they're all turned towards you for the triumph of my will because their glory in heaven
will not be complete if my will does not have its complete triumph on the earth so he's going to show
us in the the next text just how extremely important that is that for the saints to experience the
fullness of the heritage that they have been given in heaven then the divine will must triumph on the
earth okay so the saints really want this badly so do the angels everything was created he said
and you need to put a vip beside this everything was created for the total fulfillment of the divine
will and until heaven and earth return into this circle of the divine volition they feel their works
and their glory and their beatitude as only halved because not having found its complete fulfillment
in the creation the divine will cannot give what it has established to give which is the fullness of
its goods of its effects of its joys and happiness and everything that it contains so those of you
who have been with me for the book of Revelation have an advantage over the others because will
heaven and earth return into the circle of the divine will you have the new heaven and the new
earth and that is Revelation 21 and 22 the new heaven and the new earth when the whole of the
earth or at least most of the people on earth will actually be in the divine will and God will
actually be raining on the earth and this is the mystery that we're already living in today
so the reason why God wants the triumph of his divine will on earth is not because he wants to
lord it over us that's what human beings do and that's what demons do is lowered it over other
people that's not it he said the reason for this is that the divine will wants to give the fullness
of its goods it wants to give the fullness of its effects the fullness of its joys and the fullness
of the happiness that it contains it wants to share itself completely with us not by halves
this is why they are all longing that Romans 8 19 again the whole of creation is longing
for this recovery my will itself is all for you and is all intent on you the divine will holds
nothing back of its graces and light and whatever it takes i love that expression
now i suggest you take that little expression up and say to the lord at some point when you're
having a sincere and deep communion with him lord do whatever it takes to make out of me what you want
do whatever it takes to bring me to the point where i can cooperate fully with your divine will and
you can be truly truly glorified in me it's a very important clue that's given to us here
so he said to louisa that i have to do whatever it takes to form in you the greatest of tragedies
which is the divine fulfillment and the total triumph of the divine will imagine the infinite
almighty ever living everlasting eternal deity giving that amount of attention to any creature
let alone us it's it's unbelievable which one do you think is a greater
tragedy watch this now louisa is being asked a question this time she gets it right
that a little light remains enclosed in the sun or that the sun remains enclosed in the little
light now she gets this one or she said it would certainly be more prodigious if the little light
enclose the sun you see that's what he's aiming at trying to get us to understand where the little
light enclosing the divine will in us it's just he's calling it the prodigy of prodigy which it is
indeed she said it seems impossible to me that this could happen and jesus immediately said what is
impossible for the creature is possible for god that quotation is directly from luke 1827
but it's the same message as was given to our blessed mother in luke 137 he said the little light
is the soul and my will is the sun we're going to go into this in a big way in the next message
my will is the sun now my will must give so much to the little light and notice that must give
and that so much to the little light so as to be able to make of it a circle and be enclosed in it
so he says I have to make you a son I have to make you a circle I have to create a bit of space inside
of you if you're to going to be this thing he has to do everything that's why he said a little bit
further back I'll do whatever it takes to accomplish this okay so my will must give so much to the
little light so as to be able to make of it a circle that's number one and be enclosed in it
that's number two and I would add a third one and persevere and since the nature of light is to
spread its rays everywhere and remaining in triumph within the circle the remaining is another
tragedy it will spread its divine rays to give the life of my will to all so okay I become a son
S.U.N. the divine will takes up its residence in me we're going to call this a throne very
shortly and from this residence he radiates out not only to the people all around you but to the
whole earth he reigns his new tabernacle he's just using different language than the word tabernacle
so it spreads its rays everywhere while remaining in triumph within this circle it will spread its
divine rays to give the life of my will to all A.W.L. means from Adam to Zachary past present and
future this is the tragedy of prejudice which the whole of heaven longs for that the divine
will would actually be enthroned in each one of us now to be enthroned in each one of us means
our total complete absolute surrender 24/7 365 right up to and including our last breath
therefore he said give broad field to my will in other words don't resist in anything
let it happen opposes in nothing so that what was established by God and the work of creation
may have its fulfillment in and through you wonderful stuff so now we're going to develop this
in the next message made the 27th and this is a long message and I might have to go over at the
time a little bit to complete it that is if I succeed and explain it so the first thing is an
experience between louisa and jesus which is normal and louisa responds and then jesus explains so
we're going to start where they usually begin I was doing my usual acts in the supreme volition she
said and an inaccessible light enveloped my little being now one timothy six 16 tells us that god dwells
in inaccessible light entering into the divine will is entering into god one john one five tells
us that god is light in him there is no darkness so she's entering into the actual presence of god
so it enveloped my whole being it made as though present to me all the works of my creator
now here she is and the divine presence is all over her of course in him she can see whatever
he wants and allows so she sees the works of her creator I had and I love you for each
created thing a motion for each motion in adoration and the thank you of gratitude for all creation
now notice that she isn't lazy it just doesn't sit there and enjoy she actually works whatever she
sees she does her rounds of adoration and praise and thanksgiving however I understood that it was
the light itself that administered to me that I love you for each thing that motion that adoration
I was just a prey to that light while it enlarged me it made me smaller and did whatever it wanted
with my littleness now she is in the actual presence of god therefore she sees things clearly that she
won't see outside of the presence of god number one she said I had and I love you
for each created thing a motion for each motion a thank you a gratitude and adoration and all the
rest of it but then she realizes that john 15 5 is actually true without me jesus said you can do
nothing and that Philippians 4 13 is also true I can do all things in christ who gives me the strength
so it was the divine will that was actually enabling her to give this response in other words he's the
prime mover he's the prime actor therefore these acts are divine
this is where we're going the origin of the act tells you whether it's divine or human
if I simply lift up a pen and put it back down again that's just a human act it's all over done
with there's no value unless added value is given to it these acts that we're talking about have
their origin in god they are divine in their origin and therefore the divine acts she said I was just
a prey to that light in other words I was there present completely open completely active responding
to the stimulus of grace that was given to me and he could enlarge me or make me smaller whatever he
wanted to do with my littleness now when I was in this state she said I was sorrowful how you can be
in the actual presence of god and be sorrowful is an entire mystery to me but we have known in the
nineteen volumes we have studied that louisa has a fixation on actually seeing jesus in the flesh
and if she doesn't see it in the flesh as far as she's concerned she hasn't seen everything
it's totally fascinating here she is in the actual presence of god and I was sorrowful because I
couldn't see my sweet jesus and I thought to myself jesus has left me she's in the actual presence of
god no wonder we need this revelation about the holy trinity that's coming up jesus has left me
she said and in this blessed light I don't know where to turn my steps in order to find him because
one can see neither where it begins nor where it ends naturally because it's eternal and so the
sheer immensity of god's presence is not something that we can comprehend at all oh holy light she said
she's submerged in inaccessible light that's the first line the second line okay she submerged
an inaccessible light and she says oh holy light let me find the one who is my whole life my highest
good now to me that's like a fish in the ocean saying oh holy water let me see something
when the water is its life so while I poured myself out because of the pain of the privation of jesus
in the heart of god she's of the pain of privation of jesus now that's her lack of understanding of
what's actually happening to her and very often the problems we have in prayer are our lack of
understanding of what's actually going on between us and god and what god is trying to say and do
and so we think we're having a problem in prayer when we're now having a problem in prayer
I always remember the story of a priest telling me oh many years ago that he went to the bedside
of a woman who was dying and she said oh father I have a terrible problem I'm dying and he said
what's your problem thinking that he was going to hear a confession you know and forgive her and
then she died in peace she said father I can't pray and he said what do you mean you can't pray
he said can't you say the our father when no she said I can't he said have you forgotten the words
and she said no it's not like that she said I say our father and I can't get beyond that she said
hours later I'm still there I said if I had your problem I'd be happy there she was in the depths
of contemplation and she didn't know took the priests understanding of what was going on between
her and god to bring peace to her soul and Jesus is going to have to explain what's going on between
Louisa and god to bring peace to her as well she thinks she's having privation of Jesus but Jesus
is the second person of the blessed Trinity and if you're if you're in the actual presence of God
he's there so Jesus all goodness she said he came out from within my interior and all tenderness he
said my daughter why do you fear I do not leave you rather it is my supreme will that it clips us
me within you now what is he clips the supreme will is this inaccessible light and what is he
clips in Jesus it is his humanity which Louisa is wanting to see and so he explains to her that his
humanity is less than his divinity and therefore if the divinity is actually manifest at this
particular moment the humanity is eclipsed something smaller so I do not leave you that's
the Joshua one five I don't ever leave you or desert you okay rather he said it is my supreme will
that eclipses me that is my humanity within you that is in your soul you don't see it in your own soul
the problem is actually inside of you both your understanding and everything else
the light of my will is endless it is infinite I want to give you Sam 36 verse 9 Lord in your light
we see light but notice that Louisa has brought her lack of understanding of what's happening
into this experience and therefore she has to be taught in the experience itself
so the light of my will is endless it's infinite its boundaries cannot be found
neither where it begins nor where it ends because it doesn't have a beginning or an ending it's
infinite on the other hand he said my humanity does have its boundaries it does have its limits
and therefore since my humanity is smaller than the eternal will I remain enrapped as though eclipsed
within it and while I am in you I give the field of action to my will I enjoy its divine operating
in the littleness of your soul and I prepare a new lesson for you and so on now I want to give you
a couple of examples of where the scriptures prepare us for this thing about Jesus being
eclipsed in light God is light and the divine will is light and Jesus has just said it's endless
that's neither beginning nor ending to it so if you go back to the transfiguration in the gospels
you are told that first of all you see the I'm going to use the word heavy humanity of Jesus
to simply emphasize the the flesh you know the material side you see that first at the beginning
and then as Jesus enters into prayer and goes into the depths of prayer he is gradually transformed
into light so he goes deeper and deeper and deeper into the divine will and therefore the light
actually takes over that was only a short experience because the apostles were there and they wouldn't
cope with this at all secondly in the resurrection Jesus is so in eclipsed in light that nobody can
see him unless he does what he's doing to louisa right now he comes out of the light comes down
and lowers himself to a lower manifestation so that they could see him and only certain people
could see him because they had been prepared both by his evangelization and by their sufferings
and his sufferings and so on so Jesus therefore appeared and disappeared this is what he's doing
with louisa all the time but she doesn't really grasp it finally in the gospel we're told that
in the ascension Jesus was absorbed into the light of god and therefore he cannot be seen by us
because we're down on this material dimension and we can't see this light we can't see him he's
eclipsed okay so when louisa enters the divine will she can no longer see the form of Jesus
the outline of him because he is light that is john 8 12 and john 9 4 i am the light
so in each case at the transfiguration the resurrection the ascension
and when louisa enters into the light jesus is present all the time
because he's the second person of the most blessed trinity and the st peter has a nice
comment on this but i didn't remember to mark it now just hold on a second it's one peter
one eight to nine when peter says to the early christians though you have not seen him
you love him and even though you do not see him now you believe in him and are filled with the
inexpressible and glorious joy for you are receiving the goal of your faith the salvation of your souls
peter is saying the fact that you can't see him doesn't mean that you are deprived of anything
it's just that you cannot penetrate this inaccessible light and this is what jesus is trying to get
through to louisa right now so jesus is with her in this experience in entering into the divinity
she can't see him because she only sees the essence of god which is god is light so he says my humanity
is smaller than the eternal will so i remain in rapt and is though eclipsed within it and while
i am with you i give the field of action to my will so he lets the greater operate rather than
the lesser and so i enjoy it's divine operating in the littleness of your soul and i prepare a new
lesson for you to make known to you more and more the wonders of my supreme will and we're going
into a big big lesson now therefore when you swim in the divine will i want you to be certain that
i am with you to be certain no more doubts even more he said i do what you do together with you
now the church has told us this all down the centuries that all our prayers are through him
with him and in him okay but he's speaking specifically here and we've dealt with this in many of the
earlier volumes that when we do genuine acts in the divine will not only do we do what jesus does
he does what we do now in the next paragraph he's going to start talking about the unity of
the light of the divine will and once he brings up this subject the unity of the light of the divine
will he's going to use this terminology from here on in so whatever he said before now he's going to
use this new terminology so this is the new lesson he has prepared for her now my daughter you must know
that the true light is not translation says separable we would say divisible you can't divide it up
separable it doesn't actually give you the correct thing there and then he gives an example of the
sun in the sky look he says the sun which is in the sky above you also has the privilege or the
prerogative and possesses the unity of ordinary light we have to put the word ordinary there because
we're going to be talking about the extraordinary reality of the divine light the light is so compacted
together so we see the sun as a planet everything is compacted together okay within its sphere so
it's not to lose one atom now that's the point he's going to be making it's not going to lose one
atom no matter what it does and even though it descends down below filling the whole earth with light
the rays of light never separate you see to use the expression the light never separates
it's not english and it doesn't communicate anything the rays of the light of the sun never
separate they don't divide up and you can't pick up one of the rays in america and hold onto it
and we pick up another one in europe and hold onto it we can't do that the rays never ever
separate from the sun it is so compact within itself it is so united it is not divisible
that it never loses anything of its solar light now he's beginning to move into explaining to us
the one point which is the singularity of god he's beginning to explain it and as usual he uses the
sun so the sun is so compacted that it actually appears to us as a solid thing in the sky
the rays of light are never divided they cannot be separated okay no matter what light or heat
or energy it gives to anything else it loses nothing now you see we can't explain that because
the scientists try to tell us that the solar flares that it is sending out light and energy and all
the rest of it we stick with this so much so that all together it spreads its rays
dispelling everywhere the darkness from the earth and all together now notice in each case
all together all the rays are together in a unit operating in an indivisible manner
this is going to be extremely important when we go down to the next paragraph
so they operate all together so in the daylight all the rays are exposed to the earth and you get
light and heat and energy and all the effects that it gives and it withdraws the light at night
it withdraws everything it leaves nothing and that's the important thing it withdraws its light
leaving not even the traces of its sessions now if we go back to a point i've already made
now i don't want to stay here all night but if we go back to a point i've already made
sending souls into the lake of sulfur is the divine light withdrawing from them
we just call it the lake of sulfur that's an image that the bible uses
they're in absolute terrifying darkness because the divine light has withdrawn
okay so we get night on the earth when the daylight is actually withdrawn from us
it withdraws its light leaving not even the traces of its atoms now let me give you that
in a different image i've been talking about jesus appearing and disappearing
the light of the sun appears in the morning and disappears in the evening
it gives us all its effects during the day takes them away at night
and jesus is describing it as operating as a single whole entity
totally compact now he's giving us a very very very good introduction to the blessed trinity
very good if the light of the sun were divisible he said
for how long would the sun have light to give you having no more strength to illuminate the earth
in other words the sun would have worn itself out long since one could say divided light
desolate earth now the big problem is divided okay so divided light desolate earth one compact
unity of light and you get all the goods that the sun can give you so the sun can sing victory
and it possesses all its strength and its effects thanks to the unity of its light now this is the
expression that's being introduced and this is the bit you remember the unity of its light
it's operating all as one piece and if the earth receives so many admirable and innumerable effects
to the point that the sun can be called the life of the earth everything comes from the unity of
the light it possesses it all comes from the fact that it operates as one compact unity
which after so many centuries has lost not even one atom okay so if it was divided light it would
be losing all the time but what the lord is saying is that the sun has lost nothing so it has lost
not even one atom of light which was entrusted to it by god and therefore it is always triumphant
always majestic always fixed and the scientists are trying to make out that it isn't and it's always
stable in its light and that's something the modern scientists don't want to accept either
and it's always singing the praises of the triumph of the glory of the eternal light of its creator
now all of that's in production so in the next paragraph now we're going into the unity and in
separate ability of the divine will which is the center of the most blessed trinity this is one of
the central messages of the 36 volumes if you don't get this you don't get divine will so put a vip on
this text now my daughter the sun is only a symbol of the eternal will and if this symbol possesses
the unity of light much more so does my will which is not a symbol what is the reality
okay the sun is merely pointing to a reality that we find rather difficult to grasp so while the sun
can be called the budding of the inaccessible light now notice the inaccessible light one timothy
six sixteen again that is the most blessed trinity and the sun is only a budding of that therefore an
early manifestation or a very light or small or unimportant showing of what this other thing is
okay and you have seen the immensity of this inaccessible light that's where we started this
message with at the very beginning you've seen it and you've seen how one does not see a globe of light
like the sun because if you see a globe of light there's a beginning and an end to it and if you
look at a model of the universe the sun is one of the smallest of the stars that's in the universe
it's actually very small it's big to us it's but it's small in terms of the universe so you didn't
see a globe because you saw something that was eternal so you saw the vastness such that the
human eye cannot arrive at seeing where it ends or where it begins because it's infinite and from
here on in we're going to have louisa talk quite a lot about this because once this is opened up
to her the lord opens up the reality to her to let her experience it more and more yet all this
endlessness of light is one single act of the eternal will this is the great singularity
it has been mentioned many times up to now but this is the first time that you get a detailed
explanation of this and therefore this entire text is completely vital for understanding all
of louisa's writings so when you look at the words that are in front of you you're being told
everything is in one act or one point and yet as far as louisa or creatures are concerned
it's vast and inaccessible it has no beginning and no ending all you have to do is try and remember
who we are in the universe it's because our solar system is only a speck of a speck of a speck
at the universe so if the solar system and that's not talking about planet earth which is so much
smaller than that if that's our size just in the created universe it means that we have no concept
at all of the greatness and the vastness of god and yet god is one single simple point everything
is in there absolutely everything so while it's utterly vast to us and it contains all the acts
that god has done and accomplished from beginning to end everything is in this one act and when we
enter into the divine will and do acts in the divine will we are entering into this one act of god
okay yet all the endlessness of light is one single act of the eternal will all of this
uncreated light now notice the uncreated we're dealing with eternal stuff all this uncreated
light is so compacted together as to become inseparable and indivisible one single point
and so more than the sun it possesses the eternal unity completely indivisible this eternal unity
in which the triumph of god and all of our works is founded everything is founded in that unity
can you see how hard we make it for god meeting with the chaos that is among humanity on earth
this triumph of the unity of the supreme will is the center of its dwelling place
it is the throne of god it is the center of the most holy trinity now what i suggest is
that you try and write this out for the first time in my life i actually rolled out what i was reading
here and if it's really actually very impressive not what i wrote but what i was trying to write
from what is written here it is really incredible so on the one hand you have the the vastness
of everything and it's all contained in this one act it's very difficult for us to grasp
something that contains everything and is only just one act and that this one shall i say entity
is the very heart of the most holy trinity and is the throne of god this unity so you see that unity
for him is essential among us and look at the disunity in the church there are 30,000 sects
of christianity for example look at the disunity among nations look at the disunity within nations
look at the disunity within families look at the disunity within ourselves you can see the enormity
of the transformation that's got to happen to us if we've got to become like god and so to come back
into god's order we've got to come back into that unity and we've got to become part of that unity
from this divine center the most refulgent rays of light begin that's where they start
and they invest the whole of heaven now watch this this is really very interesting so here you have
the center of the most holy trinity the rays of light come out from there just as the rays of
light come out from the sun during the day okay and it invests the whole of the celestial fatherland
so all the saints and the angels are invested with the unity of the divine will so that means
that all the saints and the angels in heaven are completely part of this unity and it explains
why when the saints sometimes come to meet us and talk to us that they talk like jesus
and they respond like him because they now are like him that's what amazed me back oh nearly 50
years ago when Saint Mactimilian Colby visited me i couldn't believe that it wasn't jesus he looked
like him he talked like him he responded like him and yet he told me he was different it's very
interesting you see the unity of the eternal trinity invests all of them and they all receive
its innumerable effects now watch this abducting them into itself so they're all taken into this
unity every one of them so they're all now thinking the same acting the same wanting the same
so if you're praying for god's holy will to be done all the saints are saying yes yes yes
it makes of them one single unity with the supreme unity of my will okay so all the saints and the
angels become one with this reality it's it's just amazing so the divine rays going out from the throne
of god actually draws them all into this reality of the unity of the supreme will these rays invest
the whole of creation and form its unity with the soul who lives in my will so now he's coming down
to us look the unity of this light of my will which resides in the center of the three divine persons
it's already fixed in you he says to louisa in other words the throne of god is already
fixed in louisa fixed means it has become stable permanent and we who are living in the divine will
what we want is that it will become fixed and permanent in us as well so the light and the act
are one there is a very bad english there the light of god and the acts of god they're one whether
they're in you or in him because the throne of god is fixed in you now while you do your acts
in this unity now notice the in not doing your acts by yourself but it's in this unity okay
they are already incorporated into that single act of the center and the divinity is already
with you doing what you do therefore this is a divine act now you have your definition of the
divine act it's as clear as daylight let's read it again while you do your acts in this unity that
means fused in the divine will and the divine love these acts are already incorporated into that
single act of the center which is the center of god the center of heaven and the divinity is
already with you doing what you do the celestial mother the saints the angels of the holy creation
all in chorus repeat your act and they also feel the effects of the supreme will watch
listen to the prodigy never before seen of that single act which fills heaven and earth with the
very trinity unifying itself with the creature that is the prodigy of prodigy's he's trying to
produce in us and placing itself as the primary act of the creature therefore these acts
are divine i can't help you with this you just have to read this so slowly and read it in prayer
and ask the lord to open your mind so we're going to be talking about our acts are divine at that
moment louisa said i could see the eternal light fixed in me and i could hear the chorus of praise
of the whole of heaven and all of creation in its mute language that's sam 19 verses 1 to 6 but who
can say everything that i understood of the unity of the light of the supreme will just as the expression
you're going to hear from now on jesus added my daughter in order for each act to be good and holy
its origin must come from god that very clearly answers a question that's usually asked in volumes
one and two what is the difference between a human act and a divine act if it's a divine act its
origin has got to come from god and behold for the soul who lives in my will in the unity of its light
her adoration her love her motion and everything else you may do begins it has its origin in the
divine trinity and therefore these are divine acts some people call them divine lives i just
like to call them divine acts so she receives the origin of her acts from god himself
and here is how her adoration her love her motion are the same adoration which the three
divine persons have among themselves the same reciprocal love which reigns among the father the
son and the holy spirit and her motion is that eternal motion which never ceases and gives motion
to all there even explanation of of acts in the divine will can't be improved on it's just
absolutely perfect but notice the origin has got to be in god for it to be a divine act
and for our acts to be divine acts we have to be living in that unity that means we're living 24
7365 in the divine will we're not doing our own will we're surrendering the human will all the time
so let's pick up again the unity of this light places everything in common you see the unity of
the light is in heaven making everything in heaven in common comes into us makes everything in common
between us and heaven whatever god does the soul does and whatever the soul does god does that's
incredible now god won't do anything that isn't divine so we have to be talking about divine acts
if god is doing more we do god by his own power notice the word virtue is wrong there the soul
by virtue of the unity of the light that envelopes her is the correct use of the word virtue that
means by reason of the unity of the light that envelopes her so there's one sentence and see
in which you see the the two uses of the word virtue so god does everything by his own power
whatever we can do it's because of our unity in that divine unity of light therefore
the prodigy of living in my will is the prodigy of god himself it's the primary prodigy
while all other prodigy's all other works good and holy ones they all remain eclipse they disappear
before the acts on in the unity of this light and then he gives an example imagine the sun
spreading its rays in the unity of life and baiting all the earth and then the creatures
placing before the blazing light of the sun all the lights that exist in the low world
the electric lights and the private lights and all the other lights as many as they could want
to put their their light would always be nothing before the sun almost as if they didn't exist
imagine lighting a candle out in broad sunlight if you waste your time and no one would even
use any of these lights or give any use to them they'd all use the sun because the sun is the great
light and all those lights would remain idle so what he's saying is that as soon as we realize
really realize the value of a divine act done in god you won't touch human acts you wouldn't dream
of it so such are all the other works he says which are not done in the unity of my will the light
of my will so no matter how good the works are they're just the little lights before the great
sun which one almost does not notice however those very lights which are useless and make no
impression and do no good when the sun is present once the sun disappears they acquire their little
value in other words you use these little lights in the night when there's no light and you remember
Matthew 5 17 where Jesus said that we have to be a light in the darkness of the world okay and so
these little lights in darkness make their own little impression they do their little good they
are light in the darkness of the night and they serve the work of man but they are never sun
they are never at this divine level so the level of above and the level of below is very very clearly
marked out here okay nor can they do the great good which the sun can do yet the purpose of creation
was that all things having come out from within the unity of the light of the supreme fiat notice
you'll get used to this expression after a while all would have remained in the unity of it now
if we had remained in the unity of it we'd have paradise on earth only the creature didn't want
that because she had free will and she didn't want to recognize this purpose so notice the she and
then the he he went out of the unity of the light of the sun of my will and reduced himself to begging
for the effects of this light almost as the earth begs its vegetation and its development of its
seeds that it hides in its womb from the sun what sorrow my daughter to reduce oneself from being
a king to a beggar and to beg from those which were to be at his service and we finish on a most
wonderful wonderful wonderful note of your nothingness i absolutely love this it's about as wonderful
as you can get under nothingness so jesus was all afflicted and sorrowful from what he has just said
and he kept silent and louisa understood all the sorrow that appears to him because she's in the
divine presence and that's why she understands it i could feel his sorrow within me penetrating
deep into the innermost fibers of my soul that's because she's in the unity of the light of the
divine will but i wanted to cheer jesus at any cost so i returned to my usual acts in the unity of his
will knowing that he easily passes from sorrow to joy when my littleness dives into the inaccessible
light of his will now if you're using your own book would you color that with green white and gold
he changes from sorrow to joy when my littleness dives into the inaccessible light of his will
will you fuse yourself as often as you possibly can even if it's just to give the sheer delight
that's been spoken about here and jesus loved together with me and love healed the sorrow
so we need to do many acts of love in the divine will then he resumes speaking my daughter he said
since i am raising you in my will oh please do not want ever to give me this sorrow so piercing
of going out of the unity of the light of my supreme fear promise me swear that you will always
be the newborn of my will the newborn means that you are completely totally absolutely dependent
and surrendered to him so de weza said my love be consoled i promise i swear and you must promise
me to keep me always in your arms and sunken in your will so that will ensure that i can do it
you must never leave me if you want me to be always always the little daughter of your will
for i tremble and i fear myself we have a good reason to fear our own weaknesses more so since
the more you speak about this supreme volition the more i feel that i'm no good and the nothingness
of my nothing makes itself felt more i love that expression the nothingness of my nothing i love
that because you don't appreciate the nothingness of your nothing unless it has been exposed to you
and you are made to rub your nose in your own tongue that's when you begin appreciating the
nothingness of your nothing when people start out they think they're holy they think they're
going places and they're going to be saints and everything and when the lord begins to show you
the absolute abject sinfulness of human nature it's slightly different and when he makes you see
what same paul said in roman seven i do the things i don't want to do and i don't do the things i want
to do when you really come up against yourself you come up against the nothingness of my nothing
and he says that's what you throw into the divine arms so this is what he says it's wonderful
jesus sine added my daughter feeling your nothingness more does not oppose the living in the divine
will on the contrary it is a duty of yours now have you had got a pen john 330 he must increase
and i must decrease one carinthians one 26 to 31 he only chooses the nothings of this world
to confound the strong two carinthians 12 9 my power is at best in your weakness but we don't
like facing our weaknesses and we don't like facing our nothingness but it's great liberation
when you get there he said all of my works are formed out of nothing that's what you get from
genesis chapter one and verse one everything is created from nothing and this is why the all
can do what it wants and he decides that he prefers us to go back into that nothingness where we cannot
oppose him that that is the safe place for us to be so that is the place where we plunge ourselves
and we stay there we stay there if the sun had reason and someone asked it what good do you do
what are your effects how much light and heat do you contain it would answer i do nothing
i just know that the light is given to me by god and it is invested with the supreme will
and that i do whatever it wants i extend wherever it wants and i produce the effect it wants so he
has a very very good description of the nothing surrendered to the all and while i do so much i
remain always nothing and the divine will does everything in me that's why their divine acts
it's the same with all my other works all their glory is to remain in their nothingness
in order to give the whole field to my will that's to give god the freedom to work
to let us operate how often we heard jesus saying in the early volumes will you let me do
let me do stop opposing it only man wanted to do without the will of his creator he wanted to make
his nothingness operate believing himself to be good at something which of course is pride
and the all feeling himself placed after the nothing think of jesus put after burrabbas
he went out of man now that is the real punishment that god can give us that if the light of the
unity of god leaves us we are left in the darkness of the abyss and the ultimate final
judgment is that the light will abandon those who have been in complete rebellion
so it went out of man who reduced himself from being the superior of all to the inferior of all
therefore he said let your nothingness be always at the mercy of my will if you want the unity of
its light to operate in you and to call the purpose of creation back to life i've kept you a long time
tonight but that is pure treasure and i please ask you to look at it over and over and over and meditate
on it